RETURNING ASYLUM SEEK SOURCE
MEXICO.
JOINING WITH US REACTION IS THE
WHITE HOUSE PRINCIPAL DEPUTY
SECRETARY HOGAN GIBLEY.
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE TO MOVE
ILLEGALS INTO SANCTUARY CITIES,
WE CAN'T DETAIN MORE THAN 20
DAYS FOR A FAMILY, I'M CURIOUS,
I'D LIKE YOUR PERSPECTIVE, WHY
AREN'T LIBERAL GOVERNORS AND
MAYORS OUT THERE CELEBRATING,
HOGAN, I MEAN THEY'VE WANTED
THEM IN THE CITIES, SOME OF THEM
PROPOSING TO ALLOW THEM TO VOTE.
>> WE HAVE A CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, WELL DOCUMENTED
ON THIS SHOW MANY TIMES.
DONALD TRUMP PREDICTED THIS,
DEMOCRATS MOCKED AND DERIDED HIM
WHEN HE SAID WE WOULD SEE A
RECORD SURGE COMING ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
HERE WE ARE, 100,000-PLUS LAST
MONTH ALONE.
IT IS INCREASING ON PACE FOR
OVER ONE MILLION THIS YEAR.
DEMOCRATS' ONLY SOLUTION, IS TO
SAY LET'S MAKE EVERYTHING THAT'S
ILLEGAL LEGAL.
IT'S COMPLETELY RIDICULOUS, THE
PRESIDENT SAID, LISTEN, I
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU ARE, YOU
AREN'T LIFTING A FINGER TO HELP
PROTECT AMERICAN FAMILIES AT
ALL, YOU SAY YOU WANT OPEN
BORDERS, DEMOCRATS, YOU SAY THAT
ILLEGAL ALIENS HAVE A RIGHT TO
BE HERE, REGARDLESS OF THE COST.
SO YOU NEED WORK WITH US, OUR
ADMINISTRATION, AND COME UP WITH
A WAY THAT WE CAN TRANSPORT
ILLEGAL ALIENS, THAT WILL BE
RELEASED ANYWAY BASED ON
DEMOCRAT POLICIES, INTO YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND YOUR DISTRICTS.
AND YOUR STATE.
THAT'S THE WAY IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY WANT THEM IN
THOSE CITIES AND SANCTUARY
CITIES WHICH ARE SET UP AS
SANCTUARIES FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS.
THEY SAY THEY WANT IT, THE
PRESIDENT SAID FINE, WE'LL PUT
YOUR MONEY WHERE YOUR MOUTH IS,
WE'LL SEND THEM TO YOUR
DISTRICTS, TELL US WHEN AND
WHERE TO DELIVER THEM AND WE'D
DO JUST THAT.
>> I FIND IT PUZZLING THAT THE
LEFT IS MAKING A LEGALITY
ARGUMENT THIS IN FAVOR OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THIS IRONIC?
IS THIS ESCAPING THE LEFT?
ONE MORE THING, IT'S
INTERESTING, JULIAN CASTRO DID A
TOWN HALL ON ANOTHER NETWORK AND
REFERRED THE THIS POLICY AS
CRUEL.
I SUGGESTED EARLIER, WHAT'S
PARTICULARLY CRUEL ABOUT IT?
I MEAN IT'S ONLY CRUEL IF YOU
VIEW ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AS A
BURDEN, AM I READING THIS WRONG?
HIS WORDS, NOT MINE.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
LISTEN, THEY SAID IT WAS TO
ATTACK OUR POLITICAL OPPONENTS,
AND IT WAS WRONG FOR US TO
SUGGEST THIS.
YOU SHOULD HAVE KASHG TRIEGZED
IT AS AN OLIVE BRAN TOO MUCH
WORK WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
YOU SAY DEMOCRATS THAT YOU WANT
ALL OF THESE ILLEGAL ALIENS TO
COME INTO THIS COUNTRY
UNCHECKED.
WE HAVE TO RELEASE THEM BASED ON
THE LAWS YOU PUT ON THE BOOKS
AND YOU WON'T CHANGE.
THAT'S FINE.
LOGICALLY, WE WOULD JUST WORK
WITH YOU, BALL GAMES ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, SAN ANTONIO,
SAN DIEGO, EL PASO, YUMA, WE
CONTINUE TO RELEASE PEOPLE INTO
THE SAME COMMUNITIES.
IT'S A BURDEN.
THE FOLKS THAT DON'T WORK FOR
GOVERNMENT, THE PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS, TELL US WE ARE
OVERTAXED, WE CAN'T DO ENOUGH
FROM OUR CHARITIES TO PROTECT OR
HELP ANY OF THESE PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO PUT THEM IN PLACE IS
A CROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE LOGICAL LANDING SPOT FOR SO
MANY OF THESE ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE
THE SANCTUARY CITIES THAT
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY LOVE, AND
THEY SAY THEY WANT THESE PEOPLE
TO COME INTO THE COUNTRY.
ILLEGALLY AND UNLAUFERL
UNLAWFULLY.
WE'RE ASKING DEMOCRATS, WE'RE
HERE TO HELP YOU OUT, WHERE DO
YOU WANT THEM AND HERE EE APRIL
HAPPY TO TAKE THEM THERE.
>> IT MUST FEEL LIKE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE YOU GUYS AND LADIES
ARE ON AN ISLAND, GETTING VERY
LITTLE HELP WITH REGARD TO WHAT
SHOULD EVERY BEEN A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE ESTABLISHING OUR BORDERS.
BUT HAVE THE DEMOCRATS PROPOSED
TO YOU, ARE THEY WORKING WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE ON ANY, I MEAN
THIS, ANY SUBSTANTIVE PROPOSAL
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WHO COME
INTO THE COUNTRY DO IT BY OUR
LAWS, ANYTHING AT ALL YOU CAN
PUT OF THE FOR THE AUDIENCE?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I'VE HEARD NO PARTICULAR PLAN AT
ALL FROM DEMOCRATS.
LISTEN, THEY'RE CHOOSING TO
STAND WITH HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE WHO POUR INTO THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND UNLAWFULLY
AS OPPOSED TO 100,000 LEGAL
CITIZENS.
THEY WON'T ADDRESS, THIS I GUESS
IT'S POLITICAL, DONALD TRUMP IS
IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND THEY
THINK THEY CAN GET THESE PEOPLE
IN THE COUNTRY AND GET THEM TO
VOTE FOR THEM ONE DAY.
WE SEE HUMAN SMUGGLING, CHILD
SMUGGLING, HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
THE DRUG CARTELS, THEY CONTROL
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE SITUATION IS SO DIRE AND SO
SAD, AND DEMOCRATS WON'T LIFT A
FINGER TO WORK WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE TO PROTECT OUR PEOPLE IN
THE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
BUT ALSO TO STOP THIS HORRIFIC
PRACTICE OF USING CHILDREN TO
COME INTO THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
WE HAVE ARRESTED, OR BUSTED UP
SEVERAL CHILD SMUGGLING RINGS IN
WHICH THEY USE THE SAME CHILD
MULTIPLE TIMES TO SEND THEM BACK
TO, YOU KNOW, EL SALVADOR,
HONDURAS, GUATAMALA, TO COME
BACK UP, THEY USE THEM MULTIPLE
TIMES.
IT'S A TRAGIC CIRCUMSTANCE DOWN
THERE AND DEMOCRATS WON'T DO
ANYTHING TO STOP IT AT ALL.
EVERYTHING THEY'RE DOING
INCENTIVE ICESES MORE OF THIS
ILLEGAL, BAD BEHAVIOR.
I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
WON'T DO A THING TO WORK WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE, TO PROTECT
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
THEIR ONLY SOLUTION IS TO LET
EVERYONE COME IN HERE, NOT HAVE
A SOUTHERN BORDER, RELEASE THEM
INTO YOUR COMMUNITIES, INTO YOUR
SCHOOLS, AND INTO YOUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE.